what are the most common questions you
receive from new Authors the most common
questions I get are how do I become a
New York Times best-selling author how
do I get my book in bookstores and um
and how do I sell to a traditional
publisher every day I'm probably asked
all three of those things
and people are still caring about
bookstores people are still caring about
bookstores because even though you know
the bookstores are slowly going away
everybody has that experience of like
going to a bookstore as a kid or
whatever your your experiences are with
bookstores that there's something so
gratifying about seeing your own work in
a bookstore
what are the five biggest mistakes
authors make when writing a book
the five biggest mistakes I'm sure I've
made all of them uh number one not
asking who your book is for number two
uh focusing on all the wrong things like
the New York Times bestseller list uh
number three not bothering to find out
if it's a book people want or if it's a
book that if it's a topic that even has
a reading audience
you know
um number four they think that uh
because people have told them they're a
good writer that they should write a
book and
um number five there's nothing
unique about it
um and people I think oftentimes School
took a lot of the creativity out of us
my favorite comment I get from people
when they read my books is I felt like I
was hanging out with you I think a lot
of people they're trying to write in
some writerly voice and what it's
actually doing is making them very basic
and very much not sound like themselves
what stops most New Riders from writing
their first book I think what stops most
new writers is this question of who am I
to write a book why should anybody care
about what I have to say and I often
tell people my life's not that
interesting but I've made it into eight
books and hundreds of Articles it's not
about what it is it's about how it's
told which is why everybody may have a
book in them but not everybody should
write the book themselves if you can get
help from a professional writer do but I
think it's like if somebody says who am
I to to put my thoughts out there who
are you not to we live in a gatekeeper
free Society now where nobody has to
tell us where the chosen ones like you
can choose yourself so why not
how does a first-time writer find an
editor for their book and how do they
know that someone that's a match for
them
uh I I do I know almost no writers
who've had success out of the gate with
finding editors it is the hardest thing
because unlike say being a surgeon
anybody can say I'm an editor so I have
seen many books many clients come to us
and they say uh here's my book it's
edited and we read it it's awful and
they say but I but I hired this editor
and I say well did the editor had they
worked on best-selling books well I
never asked well what was their
experience what did and and they you
don't know what you don't know so when
you're looking for an editor the first
thing you should do is get not
necessarily references you don't need to
reach out to the people but find out
what books they worked on if they said
they worked on big books see if they're
actually thanked in those books
um if you can always give someone a
sample give them five pages and most
editors will do a sample so you can get
you know a sense of what they're going
to do and you need to understand what
editing is there's a developmental edit
which is uh chapter three belongs in
chapter 10 chapter 4 should not be there
this doesn't make sense then there's a
copy edit which is basically oh you
spelled this word wrong on this comma
and that thing and then there's a
proofread because even though the copy
editor is trained in copy editing he's
still a human being so they're gonna
miss things we actually do an audio edit
where we have computer software that
reads the book aloud because the eyes
fill in words that aren't there so you
can literally five have experienced
editors can look and still like have a
major word missing
um so they you definitely should not
trust anybody who says they're an editor
and if you find a good editor hold on to
them because they are hard to find
and what if you are continually told you
should write a book why you have great
stories but then you say to yourself
I don't know if I want to go that far
with some of these stories and then they
say well
but it'd be too interesting to you don't
want to leave this out this is this is
the meat of your book How do you how do
you reconcile that so you're told you
should write a book your story is so
interesting but there's certain things
you're squeamish about how far do you go
I
um a lot of people uh are nervous about
telling certain parts of their story
particularly if they're running a memoir
and it involves other people and this
comes up all the time and people will
say to me oh I'm going to write under a
pen name because I don't want you know
um I think it really really clear a lot
of us
um are constricted because our stories
involve other people and those other
people may not want those stories out
there or whatever it is
um I think only do what you're
comfortable with I have absolutely left
things out because in the end you know
if the people are still live I don't
think it's a good idea to put it out
there but um you know the nice thing
about the world that we live in today
with the way publishing works you can
put it out there and if you go you know
what I actually wish you know what I
feel more comfortable now now people are
thinking me as a writer I want to take
that back and add more remove it from
Amazon remove it from Ingram you can
redo it and re-upload it and all the new
copies will be that way and that's one
of the glories of uh not being
traditionally published you can change
your book at any time
what is a bismar
so my book make your mess your Memoir I
wanted to write a book about how to
write but I didn't feel like I had a
full book in me and I thought you know
I'm so I can't just tell people what to
do for 300 Pages that's so boring and
I'm somebody who a lot of business books
that I read I get a lot out of them but
I find them kind of boring and then
there are Memoirs I read where I'm
riveted by every page but I leave
without any takeaways or anything to
really do so I thought what if I could
combine them both tell my story that's
the Memoir part and then have four
chapters that are the business part
here's how you can tell your own Memoir
and so I coined the term Biz War
it hasn't really taken off yet but maybe
after this video it will why is
non-fiction or Memoir more attractive to
Publishers Than Fiction
I actually don't know that that's true
um I I don't honestly I don't know what
Publishers mainstream Publishers want
mainstream Publishers want what they
already know is going to sell so it's
not like you know if JK Rowling has a
new fiction that's very interesting
um they're just it's a business like
anything else so I don't know that
non-fiction is more attractive to them
Than Fiction but um they just want
what's successful